[موسيقى]
ربما يكون تغير المناخ هو القضية الأكثر
إلحاحًا التي يواجهها العالم اليوم
مع استمرار درجات الحرارة ومستويات سطح البحر
في الارتفاع.
من أقدم الأحداث الرياضية وأكثرها شهرة
في العالم
في السنوات الأخيرة ، كانت المنظمة
رائدة في تعزيز
الاستدامة في الرياضة ،
لذلك بالنسبة لأنفسنا في RNA كمؤسسة ،
نحدد هدفنا على
أنه العمل على جعل لعبة الجولف أكثر
جاذبية وشمولية
ولضمان ازدهار الرياضة في
غضون 50 عامًا من الآن ،
فعندما ننظر إلى خطة التنمية طويلة الأجل
للرياضة التي
تجلب أشخاصًا جددًا إلى الرياضة
لتوسيع نطاق
وصولها إلى ملاعب الجولف ، فإن مرافق الجولف تقع
في صميم ذلك
و  يجب أن يكونوا مستدامين
في عام 2018 ، حيث أطلق اليوم مبادرة ملعب
الجولف 2030 التي
تهدف إلى توفير البحوث
والحلول لجعل الرياضة م  مستدام للخام في
جميع أنحاء العالم
في مجالات تتراوح من استخدام المياه إلى الأنواع العشبية
وتعليم الحارس الأخضر ، لذلك في rna
نعلم أن لدينا دورًا مهمًا
كهيئة إدارية من حيث
زيادة الوعي
واتخاذ مكانة قيادية للمساعدة في
إحداث التغيير في الاستدامة
جدول الأعمال
الذي نعمل به مع 144 دولة مختلفة
ونجد أن الاستدامة
تتحرك بسرعة عالية في جدول الأعمال من حيث
الموضوعات الإستراتيجية المهمة
لمطوري مرافق الجولف
الاتحادات الوطنية
لأننا نستطيع جميعًا أن نرى الآن أننا
نتطلع إلى الأمام في العقود القادمة
التي نريدها  للتأكد من أن الرياضة
مرنة ، فهي مستدامة
وقوية ، وجد تقرير للأمم المتحدة في عام 2019 أن حوالي
مليون
نوع من الحيوانات والنباتات معرضة الآن
لخطر الانقراض
في العام الماضي ، أعلنت RNA عن
شراكة مع الجمعية الملكية
لحماية الطيور بهدف ضمان
أن ملاعب الجولف
يمكن أن توفر موائل للأنواع المحلية
حيث
تستمر المناطق الحضرية في النمو
عندما ننظر إلى لعبة الجولف  الدورات بشكل
شامل ونحن ندرك أنها
مناطق مهمة بشكل لا يصدق من المناظر الطبيعية ،
لقد فقدنا الكثير من
مساحاتنا الخضراء وهذا يضع الكثير من الضغط
على حياة الطيور
من حيث أرض التعشيش من حيث
أرض التكاثر
وقد أدركنا  أنه من المهم جدًا ،
بصفتنا مشغلين لمنشآت الجولف كمطورين ،
أن نفكر أيضًا
في فوائد الموائل التي يمكننا إدراكها من
خلال على سبيل المثال الحفاظ على
أنواع معينة من الموائل
حتى تشجيع أنواع معينة من
الموائل
[تصفيق]
محرك rna لرياضة أكثر استدامة
تمتد أيضًا إلى حدثهم الرئيسي
، البطولة المفتوحة ، وفي عام 2019
، أصبحت البطولة واحدة من أولى
الأحداث الرياضية العالمية لإزالة
زجاجات المياه البلاستيكية ذات الاستخدام الواحد التي
رأيناها في السنوات الأخيرة أن واحدة من
أكثر
المشكلات إثارة للقلق التي نواجهها على
مستوى العالم
تلوث محيطاتنا الناجم عن البلاستيك الذي يستخدم مرة واحدة ،
لذا في
حدثنا المفتوح الذي نظمنا فيه
أقدم ألعاب الجولف الكبرى ،
من الناحية المنطقية ، كنا نعتمد على
زجاجات المياه البلاستيكية التي تستخدم مرة واحدة ، وهذه هي
الطريقة التي نوفر بها الماء
للاعبين للجماهير للمسؤولين
في
الموقع ونظرًا لأننا نلعب في
ملاعب غولف الوشق
بجوار المحيط ، علمنا أنه من
المهم للغاية أن  لقد
أجرينا هذا التغيير بأنفسنا
وسعدنا بتقديم نموذج إلى واقع
يمكننا من خلاله التخلص تمامًا
من زجاجات المياه البلاستيكية التي تُستخدم مرة واحدة في جميع
أنحاء الحدث وفعلنا ذلك من خلال توفير
محطات تعبئة مياه مجانية في الموقع لتشجيع
الناس على إحضار عبواتهم القابلة لإعادة التعبئة.
الزجاجة إلى المكان
ثم التزويد عبر الحدث
بزجاجات المياه القابلة لإعادة التعبئة المصنوعة من الفولاذ المقاوم للصدأ
يؤثر تغير المناخ علينا جميعًا وقد
أخبرنا أننا جميعًا بحاجة إلى لعب دورنا
في حدث 2021 قاب
قوسين أو أدنى ، ربما
يمكن أن تستمر البطولة المفتوحة في الظهور  مثال على ذلك حيث تهدف لعبة الجولف
إلى مستقبل أكثر استدامة